there's a life cycle
right
your teens your 20s your 30s and so on
and every phase is a little bit
different or quite a bit different and
people have asked me uh in their 20s
what is good advice for their 20s and I
gave that and now I've gotten some
questions of what is good advice for
people in their 40s and so I'll just
pass along some thoughts
okay that's your midlife you know that
in history and when you look at
happiness that's measured as the
toughest part of life it's a midlife
they talk about midlife crisis and it's
a difficulty because you have to juggle
your work and your family you um and
it's not just your immediate family
maybe your parents your children you're
trying to be successful in life and you
find out maybe that life is tougher than
you expected and so that midlife crisis
is the key thing okay what would I
recommend first of all
I recommend for every phase of your life
meditation if you can meditate and you
have the calmness and the Equanimity to
look at that I think that that's an
important thing and then I think also
that if you think about the
relationships that you're in that then
maybe more strained
um to differentiate those relationships
who are the people that you want to be
around and how do you work with them to
get you through those issues and then on
the issue of there's too much to do you
know too much work and and
think how you get leverage think about
how you get the more out of an hour than
you did before it's all a matter of
Leverage if you know how to leverage
yourself well then you're going to be
able to get more life out of life so
don't think it's just a matter of a
choice I have to give up this or give up
that think about how you can do the
leverage a lot of these things are dealt
with in you know my book principles for
life and work so I can't cover the ball
but I would say that those that's the
expectation you're going to go through
that probably the challenging Savor the
joys in life meditate and I also think
about think about how you prioritize and
organize yourself so that you go through
that in the best possible way